welcome to Simply learn in this video we
will see what is azure Azure Services
uses of azure and how Azure is better
than other cloud services but before we
begin consider subscribing to Simply
learn and hit the Bell icon to never
miss any updates from us what is azure
what's the big cloud service provider
all about so Azure is a cloud computing
platform provided by by Microsoft now
it's basically an online portal through
which you can access and manage
resources and services now resources and
services are nothing but you know you
can store your data and you can
transform the data using services that
Microsoft provides again all you need is
the internet and being able to connect
to the Azo portal then you get access to
all of the resources and their services
in case you want to know more about how
it's different from its rival which is
AWS I suggest you click on the top right
corner and watch the AWS versus a video
so that you can clearly tell how both
these cloud service providers are
different from each other now here are
some things that you need to know about
his year it was launched in February 1st
2010 which is significantly later than
when AWS was launched it's free to start
and has a pay per use model which means
like I said before you need to pay for
the services you use through aor and one
of the most important selling points is
that 80% of Fortune 500 companies use
Azure Services which means that most of
the bigger companies of the world
actually recommend using AZ and then Azz
supports a wide variety of programming
languages the cop no JS Java and so much
more another very important selling
point of aor is the amount of data
centers it has across the world now it's
important for a cloud service provider
to have many data centers around the
world because it means that they can
provide their services to a wider
audience now Azor has 42 which is more
than any cloud service provider has at
the moment it expects to have 12 more in
a period of time which brings its total
number of regions it covers to 54 now
let's talk about Azure Services now
Azure Services have 18 categories and
more than 200 services so we clearly
can't go through all of them it has
services that cover compute a and
machine learning integration management
tools identity devops web and so much
more you're going to have a hard time
trying to find a domain that Azure
doesn't cover and if it doesn't cover
now you can be certain they're working
on it as we speak so first let's start
with the compute Services first virtual
machine with this service what you're
getting to do is to create a virtual
machine of Linux or Windows operating
system it's easily configurable you can
add RAM you can decrease RAM you can add
storage remove it all of it is possible
in a matter of seconds now let's talk
about the second service cloud service
now with this you can create a
application within the cloud and all of
the work after you deploy it deploying
the application that is is taken care of
by aor which includes you know
provisioning the application load
balancing ensuring that the application
is in good health and all of the other
things are handled by aure next up let's
talk about service fabric now with
service fabric the process of developing
a micros service is greatly simplified
so you might be wondering what exactly
is a microservice now a microservice is
basically an application that consists
of small applications coupled together
next up functions now with functions you
can create applications in any
programming language that you want
another very important part is that you
don't have to worry about any hardware
components you don't have to worry what
Ram you require or how much storage you
require all of that is taken care of by
Azure all you need is to provide the
code to Azure and it'll execute it and
you don't have to worry about anything
else now let's talk about some
networking Services first up we have
Azor CDN or or the content delivery
Network now the Azo CDN service is
basically for delivering web content to
users now this content is of high
bandwidth and can be transferred or can
be delivered to any person across the
world now these are actually a network
of servers that are placed in strategic
positions across the world so that the
customers can obtain this data as fast
as possible next up we have Express R
now with this you can actually connect
your on promise Network on to the
Microsoft cloud or any of the services
that you want through a private
connection so the only communication
that happens is between your on promised
Network and the service that you want
then you have virtual Network now with
virtual Network you can have any of the
Azure Services communicate with each
other in a secure manner in a private
manner next we have azur DNS so azur DNS
is a hosting service which allows you to
host their DNS or domain name system
domains in Azure so you can host your
application using azure DNS now for the
storage Services first up we have dis
storage with dis storage you're given a
costeffective option of choosing HDD or
solid state drives to go along with your
virtual machines based on your
requirements then you have blob storage
now this is actually optimized to ensure
that they can store massive amounts of
unstructured data which can include Text
data or even binary data next you have
file storage which is a managed file
storage and can be accessible via the
SMB protocol or the server message block
protocol and finally you have q storage
now with Q storage you can provide
durable message queueing for an
extremely large workload and the most
important part is that this can be
accessed from anywhere in the world now
let's talk about how a your can be used
firstly for application development it
could be any application mostly web
applications then you can test the
application see how well it works you
can host the application on the internet
you can create virtual machines like I
mentioned before with the the service
you can create these virtual Machines of
any size or Ram that you want you can
integrate and Sync features you can
collect and store metrices for example
how the data Works how the current data
is how you can improve upon it all of
that is possible with these services and
you have virtual hard drives which is an
extension of the virtual machines where
these services are able to provide you a
large amount of storage where data can
be stored talk about Azure in great
length and breadth and if you're looking
for a video that talks and walks you
through all the services in Azure then
this could be one of the best video you
could find in the internet and without
any further delay let's get started
everybody likes stories it so let's get
started with a story in a city not so
far away a CEO had plans to expand his
company globally and called one of his
IT personnel for an IT opinion and this
guy has been in the company for a long
time and is very seasoned with the
company's infra and he nicely answered
the questions with what he foresaw and
he said I have a good news and a bad
news for us to go Global and he starts
with the good news he said sir we're
well on our way to become one of the
world's largest shipping company and the
bad news is however our data centers
have almost run out of space and setting
up new ones around the world would be
too expensive and very time consuming
now the IT personnel let's call him Mike
now he explains the situation from how
he saw it but the CEO had done some
homework about how he was going to do it
and he answered Mike saying don't worry
about that Mike I've come up with a
solution for a problem and it's called
Microsoft Azure well Mike is an
hardworking and harnessed IT
professional working for that company
but he did not spend time on learning
the latest Technologies and he asked
this question very honestly oh how does
it solve a problem and the CEO begins to
explain Azure to Mike and he starts with
what is cloud computing and then he goes
on and talks about Azure and the service
is offered by Azure and why Azure is
better than the other Cloud providers
and what are the great companies that
uses Azure and how they got benefited
out of it and then he winds it all up
with the use cases of azure so he begins
his explanation saying Microsoft Azure
is known as the cloud service provider
and it works on the basis of cloud
computing now Microsoft Azure is
formerly known as Windows Azure and it's
a microsofts public cloud computing
platform it also provides a range of
cloud services including some of them
are compute analytics storage and
networking we can always pick and choose
from these services to develop and scale
our applications or even plan on running
existing applications in the public
Cloud Microsoft Azure is both a platform
as a service and infrastructure as a
service let's now fit their conversation
out and let's talk about what is cloud
computing Azure services offered by
Azure how is azure leading when compared
to other cloud service providers and
what are the companies that are using
Azure let's talk about that in simple
terms cloud computing is being able to
access compute services like servers
storage database networking software
analytics intelligence and a lot more
over the Internet which is the cloud
with the uh flexibility of the resources
that we use like anytime I wanted
resource I can use one and it becomes
available immediately and anytime if I
want want to retire and resoures I can
simply retire at resoures and not pay
for it and we also typically pay only
for the services that we use and this
helps greatly with our operating cost to
run our infrastructure more efficiently
and scale our environment up or down
depending on the business needs and
changes and all the servers and storages
and databases and networking all that
are accessed to through the network of
remote systems or remote computers
hosted in the internet typically in the
providers data center which is azure in
this case now we don't use any physical
server or an on premises server here
well we still use physical servers and
VMS you know hosted on a hardware or a
physical server but they're all in the
provider's environment and none of them
it on premises or in our data center we
only access them remotely it looks and
feels the same except for the fact that
they are in a remote location we access
them remotely do all the work remotely
and when we're done we can shut it down
and not pay for them so some of the use
cases some of the use cases of cloud
computing are creating applications and
services the other use cases are storing
or using cloud for storage alone if
there is one thing that ever grows in an
organization is the storage every new
day there is a new storage requirement
and it's very Dynamic it's very hard to
predict and if we go out and buy a big
storage capacity up front and until we
use the storage capacity fully the empty
storages you know we wasting money on
them so instead I can go for a storage
which scales dynamically that's in the
cloud put storage or put data in the
cloud and pay only for what you're
storing and for the next month if you
have deleted or flushed out some files
or data pay less for it so it's a very
Dynamic storage in the cloud and a lot
of companies are getting benefited from
storing data in the cloud because of its
uh dynamic in nature and the cost that
comes along with it the cheap cost that
comes along with it and also they give a
lot of the providers like Azure they
give a uh data replication for free they
promise an SLA along with the data we
store in the cloud so there's an SL
attached to it and they also provide
data recoveries as well if in case
something goes wrong with the physical
disk where our data is stored Azure
automatically makes our data available
from the Redundant or other places where
it had stored our data because of the s
they wanted to keep the other use case
for Azure is hosting websites and
running blogs using the compute service
be it storing music and letting your
users stream the music Azure is a good
place to store music and stream the
music with the benefit of CDN content
delivery Network which allows us to
stream a video or audio files with great
speed you know with that with Azure our
audio or video application works
seamlessly because they are provided to
the client with very low latency and
that improves the customer experience
for our application Azure compute
service is a good place for delivering
software on demand there are a lot of
softwares embered softwares that we can
buy using Azure and everything on a pay
asigo service model so anytime we need
need a software we can go out and
immediately buy the software for the
next 1 hour or 2 hour let's say and use
them and then return it back we not
bound to any yearly licensing cost by
that a your Computing Services has
analytic available for us with which we
can analyze get a good visualization of
what's going on in a network be it logs
be it the performance be the metric you
know instead of looking at logs and
searching logs and trying to do manual
things over the heaps and heaps of logs
that we have saved Azure analytics
Services helps us to get a good visual
of what's going on in the network where
have we dropped where have we increased
what's causing what's the major driver
what is the top 10 errors that we get in
the server in the application stuff like
that those can be easily gathered from
the Azure analytic Services now cloud is
really a very cool term for the internet
a good analogy would be looking back
anytime we look at a diagram when we do
not know how things are transferred we
simply draw a cloud right for example a
mail gets sent from a person in one
country to a person in the other country
the a lot of things happening in between
from the time you hit the send button
and the time the the person hits the
read button right and we the simple and
the easiest way of putting it in a
picture is simply draw a cloud and on
the one end one person will be sending
the email and on the other end the other
person will be reading the email so uh
cloud is a really cool term for the
internet now that's some Basics about
cloud computing now that we've
understood about cloud computing in
general let's talk about Microsoft Azure
as a cloud service now Microsoft Azure
is a set of cloud services to build
manage and deploy applications on a
network with the help of Microsoft
azures Frameworks now Microsoft Azure is
a Computing service created by Microsoft
basically for building testing deploying
and managing applications and services
through a Global Network of Microsoft
managed data centers now Microsoft J
provides SAS which is software as a
service and PAs which is platform as a
service and I infrastructure as a
service and they support many different
programming languages tools and
framework and those tools and framework
include both Microsoft specific and
third-party software now let me pick and
talk about a specific service for
example management Azure automation
provides a way for us to a automate the
manual long running and frequently
repeated tasks that are commonly
performed tasks both in cloud and
Enterprise environment it saves a lot of
time and increases the reliability and
it kind of gives a good administrative
control and even schedules the task
automatically to be performed on a
regular basis to give you a quick
history of Microsoft Azure it was
launched on 1st February 2010 and it was
awarded or it was called an industry
leader for infrastructure and platform
as a service by Gartner now Gartner is
the world's leading research and
advisory company this Microsoft Azure
supports a number of programming
languages like C Java and python all
these School Services we get to use and
pay only for how much we use for example
if we use for an R we only get to pay
for an R even the costliest system
available if you use them for an hour we
only pay for that particular hour and
then we're done no more billing on the
resource that we have used Microsoft
Azure has spread itself more than 50
regions around the world so it's quite
easy for us to pick a region and know
start provisioning and running our
applications probably from day one
because the infrastructure and the tools
and Technologies needed to run our
application are already available all
that we have to do is come at the code
in that particular region or build an
application and launch it in that
particular region and they become live
starting day one now because we have 50
regions around the world we can very
carefully design our environment to
provide low latency services to our
customers all right instead of In
traditional data center let's say you
know customers will have to or their
request will have to travel all the way
around the globe to reach a data center
which lives in the other side of the
planet and this adds more latency to it
and it is really not feasible to build a
data center uh near each customer
location because of the cost involved
but with Azure it's possible Azure
already has data centers around the
world and all that we have to do is just
pick a data center build an environment
there they're available starting day one
number one and also the cost is
considerably saved because we are using
a public Cloud instead of an physical
infrastructure to serve those customers
from a very local location and these
services that a your is offering is ever
increasing as of now as you speak we
have like 200 plus services offered and
uh they span through different domain or
different platform or different
Technologies available within the Azure
console portal now we're going to talk
about that later in this section so hold
your breath till we talk about it but
for now just know that we have like 200
plus services offered by Azure let's now
talk about different services and aure
starting with artificial intelligence
plus machine learning where we have a
lot of tools and
Technologies so the wide variety of
services available on Azure in includes
artificial intelligence plus machine
learning plus analytic services to get
an or to give us a good visual of how
the data or how the application is
performing or the type of the category
of data stored and to read from the logs
and variety of compute Services
different VMS with different size and
different operating systems different
containers available different type of
databases available a lot of developer
tools that are available for us and
identity service to manage our users in
the Azure cloud and those users can be
integrated or Federated with let's say
Google Facebook you know LinkedIn so
they are some external Federation
Services they can be used to integrate
with our identity system iots iot
Services iot tools and Technologies
available and management tools to manage
the use users you know creating identity
one and then managing them on top of it
is a totally different thing and we have
tools Technologies to manage the uh
users cool services for data migration
data migration is now made simple tools
and Technologies available for mobile
application uh development and I can
plan my own network in the cloud with
the networking Services I can Implement
my own security both Azure provider and
third party Security Services on Azure
Cloud that's now possible and lot of
storage options available in the cloud
so these are just a glimpse of the big
list of services available in Azure
Cloud so that was a glimpse of what's
available in the cloud let's talk about
the services in specific let's take
compute for example you know whenever
we're building a new application or
deploying existing ones the Azure
compute service provides the
infrastructure we need to run and
maintain our application we can easily
tap in the capacity that Azure cloud
service has and we can scale our compute
requirement on demand we can also
containerize our application we have the
option of choosing windows or Linux v
machine and take the advantage of the
flexible options asure provides for us
to migrate our VMS to Azure and lot more
and these compute Services also include
a full-fledged identity solution meaning
integration with active directory in the
cloud or in on premises and lot more
let's look at some of the services that
this compute domain provides some of the
services the computer domain provides
are virtual machines and this Azure
virtual machines gives us the ability to
develop and manage a virtual computer
environment or a virtualized environment
inside azures Cloud environment that to
in a virtual private Network now we will
talk about virtual private Network at a
later point but as of now just know that
there are a lot of services available in
Azure compute service that we can get
benefited from we can always choose from
a very wide range range of computer
options for example you know we have an
option to choose the operating system we
have the option to choose whether the
system should be in on premises or in
the cloud or do we want to maintain the
environment both in on premises and in
the cloud we have the option of choosing
the operating system whether we want to
use our own operating system with some
software attached uh to it or do we want
to go and buy the operating system from
the cloud from aure Marketplace and
these are just a few of the options
available for us when we want to buy the
compute environment and these computer
environments are easily scalable meaning
we can easily scale our VM instances
from one instance to thousands of
virtual machines in a matter of minutes
or simply put in a couple of button
clicks and all these services are
available on a pay for what we use model
meaning there is no up front cost we use
the service and then pay for the
services that we have used there's no
literal long-term commitment when it
comes to using virtual machines in the
cloud and these most of the services are
built on a payper minute billing basis
all right and at no point because of the
payper minute billing model at no point
we will be overpaying for any of the
services that's that's a TR Ive isn't it
now let's talk about bat service now bat
service is always independent regardless
of whether you choose windows or Linux
it's going to run fairly well and with
bat service we can take advantage of the
environment's unique features and not
only that in short the batch service
helps us to manage the whole batch
environment and also it helps to
schedule the jobs now this Azure batch
service is actually runs on a large
scale parallel and high performance
Computing because of that batch jobs are
highly efficient in Azure and when we
run batch services this Azure batch
creates a pool of computer nodes and uh
installs the needed applications that we
want to run and then it schedules jobs
to those individual nodes in those pools
as a customer there is no need for us to
install a cluster or there is no need
for us to install a software that
actually schedules the jobs or even to
manage or even to scale those
infrastructure or the software because
everything is managed by Azure and this
bat service is a platform as a service
there is no additional charge for using
this batch service except for I mean the
only charges that we'll be paying is for
the virtual machines that the service
uses and uh the storage that we will be
using of course and uh the networking
services that we would be using for this
batch service let's summarize this batch
service we have a choice of operating
system that we can pick and use and it
scales by itself now the alternative for
the batch would be cues but in cues
we'll have to pre-provision and pay for
the infrastructure even if we're not
using it but with a batch we only pay
for what we use and this batch service
helps us to manage uh the application
manage the scheduling as a whole as if
they are just one thing as next thing in
computer domain let's talk about this
fabric service now this fabric service
is actually a distributed system
platform that helps us to package deploy
and manage a scalable and a very
reliable microservice and containers and
what does it help this Azure fabric
service helps us or it helps the
developers and administrators so they
can avoid the complex infrastructure
problems and they can focus only on
implementing workloads are taking care
of their development taking care of
their application instead of spending
time on infrastructure so what's service
fabric service fabric it provides
runtime capabilities and uh life cycle
management to applications that are
composed of microservices no
infrastructure management at all and
with service fabric we can easily scale
the application to tens or hundreds or
even to thousands of machines here
machines represent containers as next
thing in compute domain let's talk about
virtual machine scale set now this
virtual machine scale set it lets us to
create a group of identical load
balanced VMS I just want to mention it
again it helps us to manage a group
identical and load balanced VMS the
number of instances or the number of VM
instances in an in a scale set can
increase or decrease in response to uh
the demand or or in response to a
schedule that we Define you know the
resources needed on a Monday morning is
not the same as that would be required
on a Saturday or a Sunday morning all
right and even within the day the
resources that would be needed in the
beginning of the business hour is not
the resources that would be needed at
noon or you know after 8 or 9 in the
evening so the demands could actually
vary in the environment and the skill
set helps us to take care of the wearing
demand or take care of the uh different
infrastructure requirement at a
different schedule throughout the day
throughout the week throughout the month
or could be throughout the year as well
the scal set also allows us to provide
High availability to our applications
and it helps us to uh centrally manage
configure and update a large number of
VMS as if they they are just one thing
now you might ask well virtual machines
are enough why would we need a virtual
machine skill set just like I said this
virtual machine skill set helps us uh
with with a greater redundancy and
improved performance for our
applications and those applications can
be accessed through a load balancer that
actually distributes uh the requests to
the application instances so in a
nutshell this virtual machine scale set
it helps us to create a large number of
identical virtual machines number one
and with scal set we can increase or
decrease the virtual machines with
virtual machine scale set we can
centrally manage and configure and
update a big group of VMS and and it's a
great use case when it comes to Big Data
or container workloads as next thing in
compute domain uh let's talk about cloud
services now this Azure cloud service is
actually a platform as a service and
it's very friendly in fact it is
designed for applications that support
scalability or an application that
requires scalability or reliability and
and on top of it you want them to be
very inexpensive to operate so aure
cloud service provides all these so
where would this cloud service run well
it runs on a VM but it's a platform as a
service VMS are infrastructure as a
service and when we run applications on
VM through cloud service it becomes
platform as a service so here is how you
got to be thinking with infrastructure
as a service like VMS we first create
and configure the environment and then
we run applications on top of it let's
look at the responsibility the
responsibility for us in VM is that we
manage everything end to end like uh you
know deploying new patches picking the
versions of the operating system and
making sure they are uh intact and all
that stuff it's all managed by us but on
the contrary with platform as a service
it's I mean it's as if the environment
is already ready all that you have to do
is deploy your application in it and
manage the platform I mean manage the
platform not as an administrator because
all the administration is taken care by
Azure like know deploying new versions
of the operating system it's all handled
by by the Azure so we deploy the
application and we manage the
application that's it infrastructure
management is handled by Azure so what
does cloud service provide this cloud
service provides a platform uh where we
can uh write the uh application code and
we don't have to worry about Hardware
simply hand over the code and cloud
service takes care of it so no worry on
the hardware at all so responsibilities
like patching what do we do if something
uh crashes is how do I update the
infrastructure how do I manage the
maintenance or the downtime in the
underlying infrastructure all that is
handled by Azure it also provides an
good testing environment for us you know
we can simply run the code test it
before it's actually released to the
production I want to expand a bit on
these testing applications so this Azure
cloud service it actually gives us an
staging environment for testing a new
release without it affecting the
existing release which actually reduces
the customer downtime so we can run the
application tested and anytime that's
ready for production all that's needed
for us to do to move it to production is
simply to swap the staging environment
into the production environment and the
old production environment will now
become the new staging environment where
we can uh add more to it and then swap
it back at a later point so it it kind
of gives us an swap capable environment
for testing our applications and not
only that it gives us Health monitoring
alerts it helps us to monitor the health
and availability of our application
there is a dashboard we can benefit from
uh when we use Azure cloud services and
that shows the key statistics all in one
place and we can also set up realtime
alerts to one when a service
availability or a certain metrics that
we are concerned about degrades as next
thing in comput domain let's talk about
functions now functions are serverless
Computing now many time if you heard
about Azure being serverless a lot of
time they are referencing or the person
who's talking to you is referencing to
serverless uh Computing or Azure
functions which is a serverless
Computing service hosted on Microsoft
Azure the main motive of uh a function
is to accelerate and simplify
application development functions helps
us to run code on demand without we need
to pre-provision or manage any Azure
infrastructure so Azure functions are
script or a piece of code that gets run
in response to an event that you want to
handle so in short we can just write a
code that you need for a problem at hand
without actually worrying about the
whole application or the infrastructure
that will be running uh that code and
the best of all the best is when we use
functions we only pay for the time that
our code runs so what does functions
provide or what does Azure functions
provide Azure functions allow users to
build applications using serverless uh
simple functions with a programming
language of our choice so the current
programming languages that are supported
is c f nodejs Java and PHP so here we
really don't have to worry about
provisioning or uh maintaining servers
if a code requires more resource yes
Azure functions handles or it provides
the additional resources needed by the
CT and the best part is we only pay for
the amount of time the functions are
running not the resources but the amount
of time the function is running as next
thing and moving to the new domain let's
talk about the container domain in Azure
now the container domain or the
container service it allows us to
quickly deploy a production ready
kubernetes or a Docker swamp cluster now
what's a container a container is a
standard unit of software that packages
of code and all its dependencies so the
applications run quickly and reliably
from one Computing environment to
another it could be testing uh to
staging to developing development
environment to staging to production or
from one production to another
production or on premises uh to cloud or
one Cloud to another Cloud vice versa
now imagine we had an option not to
worry about the VM and just focus on the
application well that's exactly what
containers helps us achieve so these
container instances enable us to focus
on applications and not worrying about
managing VMS or not worrying about the
learning the new tools required to
manage the VMS or even the deployment
and our applications that we create they
run in a container and running in a
container is what helps us to achieve
all these not being able to manage or
not needing to manage the virtual
machines so these containers uh they can
be deployed into the cloud using a
single command if you're using command
line interface and a couple of button
clicks if we are using the Azure portal
and these containers are kept
lightweight but they are equally secure
as virtual machines let's talk about
container service as next thing uh the
container service or uh sometimes called
as Azure kubernetes service it helps us
to manage the containers container is
one thing and a service that's used to
manage the container is another thing
now this kubernetes service or ACS it
helps us to manage the containers so
let's expand on this a bit so this Azure
container service or ACS it it actually
provides a way uh to simplify the
creation configuration and management of
a cluster of virtual machines that are
preconfigured to run containerized
applications on top of them and
deploying them deploying these
containers might take like 15 to 20
minutes or deploying the virtual
machines that run containers in it might
take 15 to 20 minutes and once they are
provision we can actually manage them by
using simple SSH tunnel into them and
this ACS when it runs application it
runs applications from Docker images
what does that mean a Docker images
makes sure that the applications the
container runs are fully portable images
are portable and u a here also helps us
to or orchestrate the container
environment not only that it also helps
us to ensure that these applications
that we run in containers can be scaled
to thousands or even tens of thousands
of containers so in a nutshell managing
an existing application into a container
and running it using AKs or ACS is
really easy or that's what it is all
about to make the application management
or migration easy now managing the
container based architecture and we
discussed that containers could be tens
or even tens of thousands of containers
so managing them is Made Simple using
this container services and even
training of model using a large data set
in a complex and resource intensive uh
environment this AKs helps us to
simplify that uh environment all right
as next thing in container domain let's
talk about container registry we spoke
about registry a little bit when we
spoke about Docker images so container
registry is a single place where we can
store our images which are Docker images
when we use when we use containers it's
it's Docker images that we use for our
image purposes so these container images
are a central registry that can be used
to ease container development by easing
the storage and management of container
images so there we can store all kind of
images like U Docker swamp or the images
used in Docker swarm or in kubernetes
everything can be stored in container
registry in Azure now anytime we store a
container image it provides us an option
for geo replication what that means is
that we can efficiently manage a single
registry replicated across multiple
regions now this Geo replication it
actually enables us to manage Global
deployments assuming we are having an
environment that requires a global
deployment so it helps us to manage
Global deployments as one entity because
we are Geor replicating we would be
updating we would be editing one image
and that image gets replicated
throughout the global uh replication
centers we would have set up and so just
one editing would have actually edited
the global images and those global
images would have provisioned the global
application so one edit replication and
then provisioning of of the applications
globalwide and this replication also
helps us to helps us Network latency
because you know anytime an application
needs to deploy it does not have to rely
on a single source which which can be
reached only through high latency
Network because we have Global
replications around the world anytime
the application wants to check back it
would check back uh the application
which is in a very nearby location for
the application itself Global
replication means that we are managing
it as a single entity that's being
replicated across the multiple regions
in the globe as next thing in a learning
let's talk about um Azure databases now
this Azure databases are rational in
fact they have uh many flavors in them
uh we're going to look at uh different
flavors SQL nosql cache type of database
that Azure offers so we're going to
learn one at a time or we're going to
learn one by one so this Azure SQL
database is a rational database in fact
it's a rational database as a service
it's managed by Azure we don't get to do
a lot of management in it so it's a
rational database as a service uh based
on Microsoft uh SQL Server database
engine and this database is a a high
performance database it very reliable
and uh it's very secure as well and this
High reliability high performance for
this high security we really don't have
to do anything it comes along with it
and it's managed by Azure and there are
two things that I definitely need to
mention about Azure SQL database that is
it's an intelligent service number one
it's fully managed by Azure and it also
has this one good thing which is it has
built-in intelligence that learns app
patterns and adapts to maximize
performance and reliability and data
protection of the application that's
something that's not found in uh many of
the other Cloud providers that I'm aware
of so I thought I'll mention it so it
uses built-in intelligence to learn
about um the user's database patterns
and helps improve performance and
protection and migration or importing
data is very easy when it comes to Azure
SQL database so it can be readily or
immediately used for analytic reporting
and uh intelligent applications in Azure
as next thing let's talk about Azure
cosmod DB now Azure cosmod DB is a
database service that is for no SQL type
and uh it's it's created to provide low
latency and uh an application that
scales dynamically or that scales
rapidly now this Azure cosmod DB is an a
globally distributed service and it's a
multimodel database this can be
provision in a click off a button that's
all we got to do if we need to provision
and Azure Cosmo DB in the Azure it helps
with scaling the database you know we
can elastically and independently scale
throughput and storage across this
database and in any of the Azure
geographic regions it provides a good
throughput it provides good latency it
provides good availability and um it
provides or Azure promises a a
comprehensive SLA that uh no other
database can offer that's the best part
about cosmod DB so this cosmod DB was
built with global distribution in mind
and it's built uh with the horizontal
scale in mind and all this we can use by
only paying for what we have used and
remember the difference between Azure
cosmod DB and the SQL database is that
Azure cosmod DB supports no SQL whereas
SQL doesn't all right few other things
about Azure cosmod DB is it allows users
to use key value graph a column family
and document data it also gives users a
number of AP options like SQL JavaScript
mongod DB and and few others that you
might want to check at the document at
at the time of reading and the best part
here is that all that we mentioned we
get to use only by paying for the amount
of storage and throughput that are
required and the storage and the
throughput can be elastically scaled
based on the requirement of that R all
right let's talk about um red is cache
discussion about azure database won't be
complete without we talking about reddis
cache now redis cache is a secure data
cache it's also called it's also
sometimes called as messaging broker
that provides high throughput and low
latency access to data for the
applications now redis cache is based on
an a popular open-source caching product
which is redis sometimes called as redis
cache now what's the use case it's
typically used to Cache to improve the
performance and scalability of A system
that rely heavily on backend data stores
now performance when we use redis cach
is improved by temporarily copying the
frequently accessed data to a fast
storage located very close to the
application now with redis cache this
fast storage is located in memory with
redis cache instead of being loaded from
the actual disk in the database itself
now this redis Cache can also be used as
an in-memory data structure store not
only that it can be used as an
distributed non- relational database and
a message broker so there are variety of
use cases for this RIS cache and by
using RIS cach the application
performance is improved by taking
advantage of the low latency and the
high throughput performance that this
redis cache engine provides so to
summarize this redis cache when we use
redis cache data is stored in the memory
instead of the disk to ensure that there
is high throughput and low latency when
the application needs to read the data
it provides various levels of scaling
without any downtime or interference now
this red cach is actually backed by redu
server and it supports u a string hashes
linked list and various other data
structures now let's talk about security
and identity Services now identity
management in specific is a process of
authenticating first and then
authorizing using security principle
and not only that identity management
involves controlling information about
those principal identities you might ask
now what's an principal identity now
Identity or principal identity are
Services applications users groups and a
lot more the speciality about this
identity management is that it not only
helps authenticate and authorize
principles in Cloud it also helps
authenticate and authorize principles or
resources on premises especially when
you run an hybrid Cloud environment so
all these services and features that
this identity management helps us to get
additional level of validation like
identity management can provide
multiactor authentication it can provide
access policies based on condition a
permit or deny based on condition it can
also monitor suspicious activity and not
not only that it can also report it it
can also help generate alerts for
potential security issues and in a way
to mitigate it can send us an alert so
we can get involved and prevent and
security accident from happening so
let's talk more about identity
management so some of the services under
security and identity management are
Azure security center now this Azure
security Center provides Security
Management and threat protection across
the workloads in both cloud and in the
hybrid environment it helps control user
access and application control to stop
any malicious activity if present it
helps us to find and fix vulnerabilities
before they can be even exploited it
integrates very well with analytic
methods that helps us to identify or it
gives us the intelligent to identify or
deduct attacks and prevent them before
it can actually happen and it also works
seamlessly with hybrid environments so
you don't have to have one policy for on
premises and one policy for the cloud
it's now a Unified Service both for on
premises and the cloud the next service
in security and identity would be keyal
now a keyal is a service or a feature
that help saf card the cryptographic
keys and any other Secrets used by the
cloud application s and the services in
other words this Azure keywall is a tool
for securely storing and accessing the
secrets of the environment I mean the
secret Keys now a secret is anything
that you really want to have a very
tight control access like the
certificates like the passwords stuff
like that now if I tell you what keywall
actually solves that would actually
explain what keyal is now keyal is used
in management it's helped in securely
storing The Tokens The passwords the
certificates it helps in Key Management
you know it really helps in creating and
controlling the encryption keys that we
would use to encrypt data it helps in
certificate management talking about
certification management it helps us to
easily provision manage and deploy
public and private SSL TLS certificates
in Azure and a lot more so in a nutshell
this key wall it provides users the
ability to provision new walls and keys
in just a matter of minutes all that in
a single command or all that in a couple
of button clicks it also helps users to
centrally manage their Keys Secrets and
policies next in the list let's talk
about Azure active directory now Azure
active directory it helps us to create
intelligent driven access policies to
limit resource usage p and manage user
identities what what does that mean now
this Azure active directory is a
cloudbased active directory and identity
management service now Azure active
directory combines and it's actually a
combination of the core directory
Services Plus application access
management plus identity protection and
one good thing about this Azure in fact
there are a lot of good things but
especially when you're running hybrid
environments you you might wonder well
how this Azure active directory is going
to behave now this Azure active
directory is built to work on on
premises and Cloud environment as well
not only that it also works seamlessly
with mobile applications as well so in a
nutshell this Azure active directory it
acts as an central point of identity and
access management for our Cloud
environment it also provides good
Security Solutions that protect against
un authorized access of our app and the
data now that we have discussed about
security and identity let's talk about
the management tools that Azure has to
offer Azure provides builtin management
and account governance tools that helps
administrators and developers that helps
them to keep their resources secure and
very compliant and again it helps both
in on premises and in the cloud
environment and these these management
tools help us to monitor the
infrastructure monitor the applications
it also helps in provisioning and
configuring resources it also helps in
updating apps it helps in analyzing
threats taking backup of the resources
build uh disaster recoveries it also
helps in applying policies and
conditions to automate our environment
we use Azure management tools and it's
also used in cost control methods so
this Azure management plays a wide role
across the Azure services and in the
management tools first comes the Azure
advisor now this Azure advisor it acts
as a guide to educate us about Azure
best practices it throws recommendations
that we can select on the basis of the
category of servers and it also provides
the impact it can have or the impact
that would happen in our n environment
if we follow the recommendations given
and recommendations are first one is the
recommendations are kind of templatized
and it throws um the templatized
recommendations not only that it also
provides customized recommendations on
the basis of the configuration on the
basis of our usage patterns and these
recommendations are not hard it's not
like something that it recommends and
then just leaves us hanging there these
recommendations provide us are very easy
to follow very easy to implement and see
results you can think of azure advisor
as an a Very personalized Cloud
consultant that helps you to follow best
practices to optimize our deployments it
kind of analyzes our resources our
configurations our usage and then it
recommends a solution for us that really
helps in improving the cost
Effectiveness improving the performance
improving High availability and
improving Security in our Azure
environment so with this Azure advisor
we can get a proactive actionable and
personalized best practice
recommendations now you don't have to be
an expert just follow the Azure advisor
and your environment is going to be good
it also helps and improve the
performance security High availability
of our environment and also it helps in
bringing down the overall Azure spend
and the best part is it's a free service
that analyzes our Azure usage and
provides recommendations how we can
optimize our Azure resource to reduce
cost and reduce cost at the same time
boost the performance helps in
strengthening the security and improve
the overall reliability of our
environment next in the list would be
Network Watcher now this network Watcher
helps users identify and gain insights
in the overall Network performance and
the health of the overall environment
now these Azure Watchers provides enough
tools to monitor to diagnose to view the
metrics and to enable or disable logs
which means you know generate and
collect the logs for resources in the
Azure virtual Network so with network
Watcher can monitor and diagnos issues
in networking without even logging into
the virtual machines with just a lot
which are real time we can actually come
to a conclusion what could be wrong in a
certain resource in a VM or in a
database you know but just looking at
the logs and not only that it's used for
analytic or to gain some intelligence of
what's happening in our Network we can
gain a lot of insight to the current
Network traffic pattern using the
security group flow logs that this
network Watcher offers it also helps in
investigating VPN connectivity issues
using d detailed logs now you might or
might not know that you know VPN
troubleshooting requires both parties or
it involves two parties and other person
the network administrator on this side
and the network administrator on the
other side and they will have to check
logs in their end and we'll have to
check logs in our end stuff like that
but with the network Watcher it kind of
takes it to the next level the logs
itself we could easily identify which
side is having the issue and suggest an
appropriate fix and the next in the list
would be Microsoft Azure portal now this
Microsoft Azure portal it provides a
single unified console to perform
various number of activities like
building not only building managing and
monitoring the web applications that we
build now this portal can be used to
organize our environment or the
appearance of the environment or the
visual of the environment nment based on
our work style and using Azure portal
users can control who gets to manage or
access the resources all from the Azure
portal and this Azure portal gives a
very good visibility on the spins that
happen on each resource right and if we
can customize it we can also identify
spend based on team spend based on days
spend based on Department stuff like
that so it kind of gives us a good
visual of where the money is spending or
where is the bill consumed within the
Azure environment next in the list would
be Azure resource manager now Azure
resource manager enables us to manage
the usage of the application resources
now we use resource manager to deploy
Monitor and manage solution resources as
a group as if it's one single entity now
the infrastructure of our application is
typical made of various components which
includes virtual machine storage virtual
Network web app database servers some
other third party services that we might
use in our environment and they are by
nature separate services but with Azure
resource manager we don't see them as
different components or different
entities instead we see them as related
services in a group that supports an
application now we kind of get the
relation between them instead of you
know letting them spread Azure resource
manager identifies the relation between
them and helps us to visually see them
all as one or single entity not only
that Azure resource manager helps or it
ensures that the resources that we
provision are deployed at a constant
rate along with the other application it
also helps users to visually see their
resources and how they are connected and
that helps in managing the resources lot
better resource Group also is used to
control who can access the resources
within the user's organization kind of
gives you the fine grained control over
who gets to access and who does not get
access and the last one in the
management tools would be Automation and
this automation gives us the ability to
automate configure and install upgrades
across High hbd environments it provides
a cloud-based Automation and
configuration service not only that this
can be applied for non aure environments
as well which is on premises so some of
the automation we could do is process
automation update management automation
configuration features automation stuff
like that and this Azure automation
provides complete control during the
deployment operation and also during the
decommissioning of the workloads and
resources with automation we can
actually automate uh time consuming or
mundane or any task that's error prone
because of uh human errors those things
can be automated so irrespective of how
many times you run it it's going to run
the same way and that really helps in
reducing the overall time and also the
overhead cost because a lot of the
things are automated which means it's
human error free which means the
application is not going to break and
keep running for a longer time with
automation we can actually build a good
inventory of operating system resources
and configuration items all in one place
with ease and this really helps in
tracking the changes and investigating
the issue let's say something happened
because we have automation because it's
logging the configuration changes it's
easy to track easy to identify easy to
identify what has changed lately that
has broken the environment go back and
fix it or kind of roll it back that
solves the problem and that actually
summarizes the Azure management tools or
Management Services now let's talk about
the networking tools or the networking
services available in Azure there are
variety of services especially
networking services that Azure offers
and I'm sure it's going to be an
interesting one let's begin our
discussion with content delivery Network
now the content delivery Network in
short CDN it allows us to perform secure
and a very reliable content delivery not
only that it also helps in accelerating
the delivery time or in other words
reducing the delivery time also called
as load times it also helps in Saving
bandwidth and increases in
responsiveness to the application let's
expand on this the content delivery
network is actually a distributed
Network of servers that can efficiently
deliver web content to users now cdns
we're going to use the word CDN here CDN
store cached content on global Edge
servers also called as uh pops point of
presence locations that are very close
to the end users so the latency is
minimized it's like taking a copy of the
data or taking multiple copy of the data
and storing it in different parts of the
world and whoever is requesting it the
data gets delivered to them from a
server which is very locally to them so
this CDN offers developers a global
solution for rapidly delivering high
bandwidth content to users by caching
the content in a strategically placed
location which is very near to them so
these content delivery networks it
really helps in handling that one
advantage you get for Content delivery
Network that's we can handle spikes and
heavy loads very very efficiently and we
can also run analytic against the logs
that gets generated in content delivery
Network which helps in gaining good
Insight on the workflow and what would
be the future business need for that
application and this just like a lot of
other services this is on a pay as you
go type so you use the resource first
and then you only pay for what you have
used the next one in networking would be
Express route now express route is
actually a circuit or a link that
provides an a direct private connection
to aure and because it's direct it gives
low latency link to Azure it gives good
speed and reliability for the Azure data
transfer it could be on premises to
Azure so it gives very good speed it
gives increased reliability and low
latency for that connection let's expand
on this a bit now this express route is
an service that actually provides an
private connection between Microsoft
Data Center and infrastructure in our
premises or in a different cocation
facility that we might have now these
Express routes do not go over the public
internet and because they don't go over
the public internet they offer a high
security reliability and speed and low
latency compared to the connections um
which are in the internet because it's
fast because it's reliable because it it
has low latency it can be used as an
extension of our existing data center
you know users are not going to feel the
difference whether they are accessing
services from an on premises or in the
cloud environment because latency is
minimized as much as possible users are
really not going to see the difference
and because it's a private line and not
an public internet line it can be used
to build hybrid applications without
compromising privacy or the performance
now these virtual private Cloud these
Express routes can be used for taking
backups if assume a backup going through
the internet that would be a nightmare
if you use express route for backups
that's going to be fast and imagine
recovering a data through the internet
from the cloud through the internet to
the on premises in a time of disaster
that would be the worst nightmare so
these Express routes can be used not
only to backup but also to recover the
data because it provides good speed low
latency recovering the data is going to
be lot sooner the next product or
service we're going to discuss in
networking is azure DNS now Azure DNS
allows us to host domain name in Azure
and these domain names come with an
exceptional performance and availability
now Azure DNS is used to set up and
manage DNS zones and records for our
domain name in the cloud now this Azure
DNS is a service for DNS just like the
name says and it provides name
resolution by using azures
infrastructure and uh by using this
domain we can actually manage the DNS
ourselves through the Azure portal with
the same credential imagine having a DNS
provider which does not even belong in
our it imagine that en en onment you
know we would have a separate portal to
manage the DNS environment now those are
gone and now we can actually manage the
DNS in the very same Azure portal where
we use the rest of the other services
and this Azure DNS very much integrates
with other DNS service providers it uses
a Global Network of name servers to
provide fast response to DNS queries and
these domains are having additional
availability compared to the other uh
domain service providers availability
promises these are going to have more
availability than the rest because most
of the servers are maintained by
Microsoft and it helps resolve sooner it
helps resyncing let's say a server fails
it kind of helps resyncing with the rest
of the servers so all the Microsoft's
environment all the Microsoft Global
Network of name servers kind of ensures
that our domain names are resolved
properly not only properly but also are
available most of the time right next in
the list in networking Services is
virtual Network I'm sure this is going
to be very interesting and I'm sure
you're going to like it so this
networking or virtual networking in
Azure it actually allows us to set up
our own private cloud in the public
Cloud it gives us an isolated and highly
secure environment for our application
let's expand on this and this Azure
virtual Network helps us to provision
Azure virtual machines and uh it helps
us to securely communicate with other on
premises and internet networks it also
helps in controlling the traffic that
flows through or Flows In and Out of
This virtual Network to other virtual
networks and to the internet now this
Azure virtual Network sometimes called
as vet is actually a representation of
our own network in the cloud it's
actually a logical isolation of the
Azure Cloud dedicated to our
subscription all our environments are
provisioned in a vnet that is separate
from another customer's vets that way we
have that logical separation there so
this virtual Network can also be used to
provision vpns in the cloud so we can
connect the cloud and the on premises uh
infrastructure and lot more especially
in a environment where we have hybrid
environment surely we will be using
virtual Network because that's going to
require VPN for secure data transfer in
and out of the cloud and in and out of
the on premises environment all right so
it kind of gives us an boundary for all
the resources so all the traffic between
the Azure resources they kind of
logically stay in between or logically
stay Within the Azure virtual Network
and here we can design the network it's
given over to us you know you can pick
the IP you can pick the routing you can
pick the subnet and a lot of freedom is
given or I would say a lot of control on
how the network is designed it's not
like something that's already cooked and
we only get to use it no we can actually
build the network from the scratch we
can pick the IP address that we like we
can pick you know which subnet needs to
communicate with the other subnet stuff
like that and like I said if you are
using hybrid environment you definitely
would be requiring a virtual Network
because it helps connect the on premises
and the cloud in a secure fashion using
VPN the last product we're going to
discuss in networking is a load balancer
this load balancer actually provides
application a good availability and a
good Network performance so how does it
work it actually works by load balancing
the traffic to and from uh the virtual
machine and the cloud resources not only
that it also load balances between cloud
and cross premises virtual networks with
azured load balancer we can actually
scale our application and create high
availability for our services which
means Our obligation will be available
most of the time if any of the server
goes dead the server does not get
traffic what happens if the server gets
traffic user is going to experience
downtime what happen happens if the
server does not get traffic user won't
experience any downtime the connection
is shifted to an healthy service so the
user experiences up time all the time so
this load balancer supports inbound and
outbound scenarios and it provides low
latency it gives high throughput of the
data transfer and we can actually scale
up the flow of the TCP and UDP
connections from hundreds to thousands
to even Millions because we have a load
balancer now in between the US user and
the application so how does it operate
this load balancer actually receives the
traffic and it load balances the traffic
to the backend pool of instances
connected to it according to the rule
and the heal probe that we set that's
how it maintains High availability so
what does load balancer help it helps in
creation of high available scalable
application in the cloud in minutes it
can be used to automatically scale the
environment with the increasing
application traffic and one feature of
load balancer is to check the health of
the user's application instance and it
removes or it stops sending the request
to the unhealthy instance and kind of
shifts that connection to the healthy
instance that way a user or a connection
does not get stuck with an instance
That's not healthy that's all that you
need to know about the networking
Services now let's talk about the
storage services or the storage domain
in a now Azure storage in general is a a
Microsoft manage service providing cloud
storage which basically is highly
available secure durable scalable and
redundant because it's all managed by
Azure we don't get to manage a lot of it
and these Azure storages are a group of
storage Services they catter different
needs and the storage products include
Azure blobs which is actually an object
storage it includes um Azure data lab it
includes Azure files as you see it
includes Azure cues it includes Azure
tables and lot more but let's start our
discussion with Azure store simple Azure
store simple is an hybrid cloud storage
solution that actually lowers the cost
of storage to nearly 60% of how much you
would be actually spending without using
it so Azure simple storage or store
simple is an integrated storage solution
that manages the storage task between
between on premises and the cloud
storage what I really like about Azure
is that it's built around a hybrid
environment in mind there are a lot of
other Cloud providers that are there
where running and hybrid environment is
a big challenge you know it has some
compatibility you won't be able to find
an hybrid or on premises and Cloud
solution for your need stuff like that
but with the Azure especially when it
comes to storage a lot of the things
that we're going to see it clearly is
designed
with hybrid environment in mind all
right so let's come back and talk about
store simple so store simple is an very
efficient cost effective and a very
easily manageable sand storage area
networking solution in the cloud I
thought I'll throw in this information
the reason why it got store simple is
really because it uses store simple 8000
series devices which are used in Azure
Data Center and this uh store simple or
simple storage it comes along with
storage steering to manage the stored
data across the various storage media so
the current the very current data is
actually stored in on premises on solid
state drives and data that is used less
frequently is stored in uh hdds or hard
disk drives and the data that requires
archived or that needs to be archived
very old data let's say less frequently
used data candidate for archive they are
actually pushed uh to the cloud so you
see how this storage steering
automatically happens in store simple
and one another cool feature of store
simple is that it enables us to create
an ond demand and scheduled backups of
data and and then store the data locally
or in the cloud and these backups are
actually taken in the form of
incremental snapshot which means that
they can be created and restored quickly
it's not a complete backup it's an
incremental backup and these Cloud
snapshots they can be critically
important when there is a disaster and
when there is a disaster recovery
scenario because these snapshots can be
called in and they can be put on storage
systems and then they become the actual
data so recovering is faster if you have
proper scheduled backups or if you have
frequent backups and this storage simple
it really helps in easing our backup
mechanism which means it kind of eases
our Disaster Recovery steps or
procedures as well so this store simple
it can can be used to automate data
management data migration data movement
data teering across the Enterprise both
in cloud and on premises it actually
improves the compliance and accelerates
the disaster recovery for our
environment and if there is one thing
that's increasing every new day in our
environment that would be storage and
this store simple addresses that need
and we really don't have to pre-plan or
or think in deep for having a proper
storage because now we have a simple
storage of available in the cloud and
moreover it's on a pay as you go type so
not much pre-planning on storage is
needed yes there would be a need but not
as much as I would without the cloud or
without the simple storage and the next
service under storage that we would like
to discuss is the data Lake store this
data Lake store or storage it's a coste
effective solution for big data
analytics in specific so let's expand
this so this data Lake storage is an
enterprise-wide repository for big data
analytic workload now that's the major
service that's dependent on this data
Lake store and this data Lake enables us
to capture data of any size of any type
and of any inje speed and it kind of
collects them in one single space or in
one single place for operational
efficiency I mean operational efficiency
and for analytic purpose how do in Azure
is very dependent on this data Lake
storage and this uh data Lake store is
designed with performance for analytics
in mind so anytime you think of or
anytime you're using analytic in the
cloud or anytime you're using Hado in
the cloud in Azure we are definitely
using or we will be to the most part or
the normal procedure or the Right
Storage to pick would be datal le store
in Azure it's designed with security in
mind so anytime we use Azure storage we
can be rest assured that we are using
storage from within a data center which
has or which was built with security in
mind so this data store also uses Azure
blob storage behind the scenes for
global scale durability and for
performance let's talk about blob
storage now blob storage provides large
amount of storage and scalability now
this blob storage is the object storage
solution for Azure Cloud let's expand a
bit on blob storage Azure blob storage
is Microsoft offering for object storage
now this blob storage is optimized for
storing massive amount of unstructured
data which could be text or binary data
it's designed and it's optimized for
Rapid reads if I explained to you on
what scenarios we would be using blop
storage that might help you get a good
understanding of what blob storage is so
it's help or it's it's designed as of
now it's being used in many it
environments to serve images or
documents directly to the browser it
helps in storing files for distributed
access a lot of Fetchers can fetch data
from Azure blob storage and it currently
helping users stream video and audio
it's currently being used for writing
log files it's currently being used to
store data as backup and restore at a
later point in times of Disaster
Recovery it also is used as an archiving
storage in a lot of cloud it
environments it's widely used in storing
analytic data not only storing but also
running analytic query against the data
stored in it so that's a wide use case
for blob storage not only that in
addition to all that we mentioned uh it
also supports versioning so anytime
somebody updates and data a new version
gets created which means at any point I
can roll back as in when needed and it
provides a lot of flexibility on
optimizing the users's storage need it
also supports uh tearing of the data So
based on need when I actually explore I
would find a lot of options I can pick
from that uh you know suits to my unique
storage environment or unique storage
need and like I said it stores
unstructured data and this unstructured
data is available for customers through
rest based object storage environment
the next product and storage service
would be Q storage now Q storage
provides durable qes for large volume
cloud services it's a very simple and a
cost effective durable messaging queue
for large workloads let's expand this Q
storage for a moment now this Q storage
is a service for storing large amount of
messages that can be accessed from
anywhere in the world through HTTP and
https calls a single Q or a single Cube
message can be up to like 24 KB in size
and a single Q can contain millions of
such 24 KB in size messages and how much
can it hold it can hold up to the total
capacity of the storage account itself
so that's kind of easy to translate How
much would it hold and this Azure Q
storage it provides an messaging
solution between applications and
components in the cloud what does it
help it helps in designing an
application for scale it helps in
decoupling the application so you know
it's not very dependent or sometimes
it's not at all dependent on the other
application because now we have a queue
in between which kind of translates or
which kind of connects or which kind of
decouples both the environment now we
have a queue in between both the
environment can scale up or scale down
independently the next in the storage
service would be the file storage let's
talk about file storage now these Azure
files provide secure simple and managed
Cloud file shares now with file share in
the cloud it actually extends the user
servers on premises performance and
capacity and lot of familiar tools for
the cloud file share management can be
used along with the file storage that
we're talking about so let's expand a
bit on file storage now this Azure files
or Azure file storage offers a fully
managed file shares in the cloud that
can be accessed via the uh SMB protocol
server message block protocol now this
Azure file shares can be mounted
concurrently by cloud or in on premises
deployments a lot of operating systems
are compatible with it windows are
compatible Linux is compatible Mac OS is
compatible in in addition to all these
being able to run on on premises and on
the cloud or being able to access from
on premises and on the cloud it can also
offer cash for caching uh the data and
keeping it locally so it's immediately
available when needed so that's some
additional feature I would say that's
some Advanced feature that it offers
compared to the other file shares
available in the market let's talk about
table storage let's talk about table
storage now table storage is a nosql key
value pair storage for quick deployments
with the large semi-structured data sets
the difference between one important
thing to note with table storage is that
it has a flexible data schema and also
it's highly available let's expand a bit
on table storage so anytime you want to
pick a schema less a no SQL type table
storage is the one we'll end up picking
it provides an key pair attribute
storage with a schema less design this
table storage is very fast and very cost
effective for many of the applications
and for the same amount of uh data it's
lot cheaper when you compare it with the
traditional SQL data or data storage so
some of the things that we can store in
the table storage are of course they're
going to be flexible data sheets uh such
as user data for web application address
books device information and other types
of metadata for our service requirements
and it can have any number of tables up
to the capacity limit of the storage
account now this is not possible with
SQL this is only possible with no SQL
especially with table storage in Azure
explanation of storage really concluded
the length and breadth of the
explanation this CEO was giving his uh
IT personnel but this IT personnel is
not done with it yet he still has a
question even after this lengthy
discussion and his question was well
there are a lot of other Cloud providers
available what made you specifically
choose Azure I mean from the kind of
question that he asked we can say that
he is very curious and uh he definitely
had asked an very thoughtful question so
his CEO went on and started to explain
about the uh other capabilities of azure
or how it kind of outruns the rest of
the cloud providers so he started or uh
he again started his discussion but from
a different angle now so he started to
explain what are the capabilities or how
Azure is better than uh the competitor
so he started with explaining the
platform as a service capabilities and
I'm going to tell you what the CEO told
his ID person so this platform as a
service or in platform as a service the
infrastructure management is completely
taken care by uh Microsoft allowing
users to focus completely on the
innovation ation no more infrastructure
management responsibilities go and focus
on Innovation that's that's a fancy way
of saying it when we buy platform as a
service that's what we get we can
contribute our time on Innovation and
not just maintaining the infrastructure
and U Azure especially is U net friendly
Azure supports the net programming
language and um it has or it is built or
designed or it is optimized to work with
old and new applic ations deployed using
net programming framework so if your
application
isnet most of the time you would end up
picking Azure I mean if you try to
compare most of the time you would end
up picking Azure as your cloud service
provider and the security offerings that
Azure offers is it's designed based on
the security development uh life cycle
which is an industry leading Assurance
process when we buy services from Azure
it aures that the environment is
designed based on security development
life cycle and like I mentioned many
times in the past and I would like to
mention it again Azure has well thought
about the hybrid environments which a
lot of other Cloud providers have failed
so it's very easy to set up an hybrid
environment to migrate the data or not
to migrate the data and still run a
hybrid environment they work seamlessly
with the azure because Azure provides
seamless connection across on premises
data centers and the public Cloud it
also has a very gentle learning curve if
you look at the uh documentation it's
picture rich and the documentations are
neat and clear would really it would
encourage you to learn more it would
encourage you to think and imagine and
try easily get a grasp of how Services
work so it has a very gentle learning
curve Azure allows the utilization of
technologies that several business have
used for years so there is a big history
behind it it has a very gentle learning
curve the the certifications the
documentations the stage-by-stage
certification levels it's all very
gentle learning curve which is generally
missing in other cloud service providers
now this would really impress the CTO or
or people working in finance and
budgeting if an organization is already
using Microsoft software they can
definitely go and Avail or be bold and
ask for a discount that can reduce the
overall Azure spending in other words
overall pricing of the Azure so that's
what helped or they are the information
that helped the CEO pick Azure as his
cloud service provider and then the CEO
goes on and talks about the different
companies that are currently using Azure
and they are definitely using Azure for
a reason like Pixar Boeing Samsung
EasyJet zerox BMW 3M they are major
multinational multi-billion companies
they rely run operate their it in Azure
and this CEO has a thought that his it
person is still not very convinced
unless and until he shows him a visual
of how easy things are in Azure so he
goes on and explains about a practical
application of azure which is what
exactly I'm going to show you as well
all right a quick project on building an
Azure app using or building a net
application in Azure web app and making
it connect to anql database will
solidify all the knowledge that we have
gained so far so this is what we're
going to do I have an Azure account open
as you see logged in and everything is
fresh here let me go to Resource Group
there's nothing in there it's it's kind
of fresh all right I'm logged in and
this is what we're going to do so we're
going to create an application apption
like this which is nothing but an to-do
application a to-do list application
which is going to run from the web app
get information from us and save it in
the database that's connected to it so
you can already see it's a two-tier
application web and DB all right so let
me go back to my Azure account the first
thing is to create an Resource Group
let's give it an a meaningful name let's
call it Azure simp L all right and it's
going to be a free trial and the
location pick one that's nearest to you
or you know wherever you want to launch
your application now for this use case
I'm going to pick Central us and create
it's going to take a while to get
created there you go it's created it's
called Azure simply learn now what do we
need we need an web app and an a
separate SQL database let's first get
our web app running so go to app
services and then click on ADD it's not
the web app plus SQL that we want we
want web app alone for this uh example
so let's create an web app uh give it a
quick name let's call it uh Azure simply
learn the subscription is free trial and
I'm going to use my existing Resource
Group a resource Group that we created
some time back it's going to run out of
Windows and we're going to publish the
code all set we can create it all right
while this is running uh let me create
my uh
database right SQL database create a
database give it a name let's call it
Azure simply learn
DB put it in our existing Resource Group
that we created it's going to be a blank
database all right and it's going to
require some uh settings like the name
of the server and the admin login the
password that goes along and in which
location this is going to be created the
server name is going to be Azure simply
learn DB that's the server name and the
admin login can be what can be the admin
login name let's see so let's call it
simply La that's my admin login name and
let me pick a
password click on create so what have we
done so far we have created an web app
and we have created an a database in the
resource Group that we have created so
if I go to Resource Group it's going to
take some time before things show up so
if I go to my Resource Group I only have
one Resource Group as of now as you
simply learn and there I have a bunch of
resources being created you know it's
still being created all right in the
meantime I have my application right
here that's running out of uh or that's
in Visual Studio as of now right so once
the infrastructure is set and ready in
the Azure console uh we're going to go
back to visual studio uh feed these
inputs in the visual studio so the code
knows what the database is the the
credentials to log into the database
stuff like that so we're going to feed
those information in Visual Studio by
that we're actually feeding it into the
application and then we're going to run
it from there deploying this application
takes uh quite a while we really got to
be patient all right now we have all the
resources that we need for the
application to run here is my uh
database and here is my app service
there's one more thing we need to do
that is um create an firewall exception
rule so one more thing needed is to
create an firewall exception uh rule
right so the application is going to run
from my local desktop and it's going to
connect to the database right so let's
add an exception rule by simply adding
the client IP it's going to pick my IP
the IP of laptop I'm using as of now and
it's going to create an exception to
access the database so that's done now
we can go back to our Visual Studio I
already have a couple of um apps running
or couple of configurations pushed from
Visual Studio I'm going to clean that up
if you're doing it for the first time
you you may not uh need to do
this all right so let's start from the
scratch this is very similar to how you
would be doing in your environment all
right so we're going to uh select an
existing Azure app service now before
that I have logged in as you can see I
have logged in with my credential so
it's going to pull few things
automatically from my Azure account so
in this case I'm going to use an
existing Azure app so select existing
and then click on
publish all right if you recall these
are the very same resources that we
created a while
back
all right we have clicked on Save and
it's running kind of validating the code
and it's going to come up with an URL
now initially the URL is uh not going to
work because we haven't mapped the
application to the database that would
be the next
thing all right so the app has been
published and it's running from my a web
app as of now it's going to throw an
error like you see it's throwing an
error that's because we haven't mapped
the app and the DB together so let's do
that all right let's do that so let's go
to server Explorer uh this is where uh
we're going to see our uh uh databases
that we have created now let's quickly
verify that go back to to uh the
resource Group right appropriate
Resource Group which is right here and
uh here I have my uh database Azure
simply learn
database
all right it has some issues connecting
uh to my database give me a quick moment
let's fix
it
all right so we'll have to map the
database into this application all right
so let's go to the solution Explorer
click on publish
and a page like this get shown and from
here we can go to
configure here is our web app all right
with all its uh credentials let's
validate the connection number
one all right and then click on
next this is my DB connection string
right which the app is going to use to
connect to my DB now if you recall R DB
was uh Azure simply learn DB and that's
not being shown here so let's fix
that right so let's fix
that click on configure and here uh
let's put our DB servers uh URL now
before that let's change this to SQL
Server all right and then in here put
the DB's URL so go back to Azure here is
my DB or serers name put that
here right the username to connect to
the server that's right here put that in
and the
password to connect to the server let's
put that
in all right it's trying to connect to
our Azure portal or the Azure
infrastructure and here is my database
if you recall it's Azure sldb that's the
name of the database Let's test the
connection connection is good click on
okay so now it's showing up correctly
Azure simply learn DB that's the name of
uh the database that we created now it's
configured
all right let's modify the data
connections right let's map it to the
appropriate database again all right so
our name of the database is is azure
simply loar
DB and then uh it's going to be SQL
Server that's the data
source the
uh username is simply learn and the
password is what we have given in the
beginning all right let's validate the
connection it's good click
okay now we're all set and ready to
publish our application again now the
application knows how to connect uh to
the database we have educated it with
the um the correct connection strings
the DNS name the username and the
password for the application to connect
to the
database so visual Studios building this
project and once it is up and running
we'll be prompted with an URL uh to
connect and anytime we put or we give
inputs to the URL that's going to
receive the input and save it in the
database all right right so here is my
uh to-do list app and uh I can start uh
creating to-do list for myself all right
so I have items already listed I can
create an entry and these entries get
stored in the U in the database I can
create another entry and I'll take the
dog for a walk that's going to get
stored I can create another entry uh
book tickets for uh scientific uh
exhibition and that's going to receive
and put that in the database and that
concludes our session so through this
session we saw how I can use Azure
services to create web app and connect
that to the DB instance and how those
two Services which are decoupled by
default which are separate by default
how I can you know use the connection
strings to make connection between the
app server and the database and be able
to create an working
app staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here